all right professor what are you what
are you what are we talking about today
i was going to talk about a paper
entitled gaia early data release 3
acceleration of the solar system from
gaia astrology professor you're loving
all these findings that are coming out
of gaia aren't you it's a brilliant
mission and actually you know i think
the best is yet to come because it's the
nature of this telescope its sole
ambition is to measure the positions of
about a billion stars and various other
objects in space and to continue to
monitor them
and the primary science goal is to
measure this phenomenon called parallax
which is basically as the satellite as
it's orbiting the earth the earth goes
around the sun which means it's sort of
viewing the nearby universe from
different places and in doing so it's
viewing things from slightly different
directions you end up seeing the stars
move a little bit and the classic way of
illustrating this is it's the same
phenomenon as if you hold your finger up
in front of your nose and then close one
eye and close the other eye and your
finger jumps just because your eyes are
viewing it from slightly different
directions and the further your finger
is away from your face the less your
finger jumps when you make that uh do
that little experiment professor this
might say something about me but i
remember like you know when hubble went
up and talk about james webb and there's
so much hype and excitement i feel like
i don't even remember guy going up i
don't remember people talking about it
just kind of one day you started telling
me look at all this amazing data and i'm
like where does this come from
i guess it's partly because it's a
little bit more specialized an
astronomer you know it's a it's a
classic subject and for the longest time
it made very little progress but then we
first had this mission called hipparcos
in the 1990s and then gaia is kind of
the successes of that which have kind of
completely revolutionized what these
telescopes could do the accuracy of the
missions what's this paper telling us
so we need to back up a little bit first
um and i need to talk about a
a bit of astronomy called stellar
aberration it sort of came with the
birth of of uh people trying to measure
parallax so back in the 18th century
there was a guy called bradley james
bradley was his name who was trying to
measure the distances to stars from this
parallax effect and what he actually
found is that the stars do indeed move
over the course of a year but in
completely the wrong pattern for it to
be the parallax effect and by far too
large an amount and what he did
uncovered was this phenomenon called
stellar aberration and he was actually
also the person not only who discovered
it but also came up with the explanation
as to what's going on why stars wobble
around over the course of the year
and in essence it comes down to if you
think about going out in the rain like
if the and imagine the rain's falling
straight down on your head if you're
standing still the rain falls on your
head and you can say oh the rain is
coming from straight up but if you start
walking then because there's now a
relative motion between you and the rain
the rain actually starts hitting you in
the face right if you're carrying an
umbrella you have to tilt your umbrella
forward you get exactly the same thing
with stars right that actually the
direction in which the starlight is
coming depends on the direction in which
the earth's moving if the earth's not
moving then you know maybe the starlight
will be coming from directly ahead but
if the earth's moving then the net
effect of that is that the starlight
appears to come from a slightly
different direction just because you had
the relative speeds together and you end
up shifting the direction the lights
coming from and of course over the
course of a year as the earth goes
around the sun its motion is in
different directions at different times
which means this effect shifts stars in
different directions at different times
of the year so this guy bradley figured
all this out and actually he used it to
make the first reasonably accurate
measurement of the speed of light
because it's all to do with you know the
amount that this effect
the size of this effect just depends on
the relative speed of the earth which
they knew compared to the speed of light
now that story is not quite true because
it turns out of course you you can't do
so this involved adding speeds right
that i said the weather speed of you
know the things traveling at some speed
and then there's the relative motion of
the earth we added speeds together one
of those speeds we added together in
this particular case was the speed of
light and you're not supposed to do that
because you run into all sorts of
relativistic effects that says actually
when you get close to the speed of light
you can't just add speeds together so
the real story is a little more
complicated in fact stellar aberration
was what led to the formation the
formulation of special relativity but at
least in qualitative terms this idea of
thinking about it in terms of rain
falling on your head still works pretty
well if we move forward to the 19th
century
um there was an astronomer called john
pond who was also interested in parallax
and he pointed out an interesting thing
which is that that was just thinking
about the earth moving around the sun
but of course if the sun's moving
relative to the stars then that should
produce the same effect what he pointed
out is that if the sun were to
accelerate or decelerate so if its speed
were to change then actually that change
in speed would lead to a change in this
effect just as if you sped up or slowed
down walking in the rain and therefore
you ought to see things move due to the
acceleration or deceleration of the sun
a little bit later in the 19th century
john herschel came along and said that's
all very well and it's a very neat idea
but of course we now know as they did by
then that the stars are all moving as
well they all have their own proper
motions so he said you know trying to
separate out the motion due to the
acceleration of the sun
from just the fact that the stars are
all moving around anyway and we can now
measure those uh is hopeless right
you're never actually going to be able
to do that and the reason why suddenly
it comes back to life again is gaia is
measuring the positions of billions of
stars but it's also measuring some other
things as well and in particular there
are about a million quasars that it's
measuring so these very distant galaxies
with incredibly bright star-like output
because their central engines their
central black holes are incredibly
bright so to all intents and purposes
they look just like stars and so gaia
can measure them but of course they
don't move well they probably do move
but there are such huge distances away
that effectively they form an unmoving
reference frame that means that if
pond's original idea was right and the
sun were accelerating then we should be
able to detect it by looking for the
aberration it induces in all these
distant quasars they'll all start to
have a proper motion just due to the
fact that the sun is accelerating over
time and so even though the signal in
any one
particular quasar is absolutely tiny
because we've got a million of them and
we know what pattern to look for we can
kind of average all that information
together to try and measure the
acceleration of the sun and that's what
this paper did
all right this brings me to the question
that's been burning a hole in my head
for the last five to ten minutes why is
the sun accelerating at all
the main reason the sun's accelerating
is because it's orbiting around the
milky way and of course to get something
to go around in a circle you have to
accelerate it it's this phenomenon
called centripetal acceleration the
movement there because it's not
traveling in a straight line its
velocity is changing that means you're
accelerating it so we actually have a
reasonable prediction as to what we
expect the acceleration of the sun to be
and also what direction we expected to
be in because
centripetal acceleration it's seeking
the center centripetal acceleration so
it's actually all should be accelerating
towards the center of the galaxy so
that's the phenomenon these guys
measured let me just read the results
our best estimates of the acceleration
based on gaia edr 3's that's these data
they look at is 2.32 plus or minus 0.16
times 10 to the minus 10 meters per
second squared so it's an acceleration
of 2 times 10 to the minus 10 meters per
second squared so that's a 0 with
0.902 meters per second squared that's
really small that's absolutely tiny it
means over the course of a year
the speed of the sun changes by less
than a centimeter per second where's the
energy coming from to do that from
gravity yeah it's just the pull of
gravity stuff so it's the the pull of
gravity is what's pulling it round
accelerating around it's just newton's
second law force equals mass times
acceleration where the force is the
gravitational pull of the galaxy towards
the center and the acceleration is the
centripetal acceleration towards the
center now the reason why it's tiny is
you you're quite right the actual
acceleration on kind of astronomical
time scales is quite large but that's
the thing you have to accelerate around
in a circle over the course of 200
million years right the time it takes to
go around
so that means the amount that the speed
needs to change each second is
absolutely tiny so we think the sun's
going around the milky way at something
like 230 kilometers per second we think
we know the distance in the center so
actually we can predict what that
acceleration more or less ought to be
it's probably a bit more complicated
because there will be local effects you
know that causing the sun to accelerate
there are nothing to do with that global
acceleration but actually it turns out
that the number they get here is almost
exactly the same as that figure you
would expect and then of course the last
bit is i mentioned that not only do you
get the size of the acceleration you get
the direction of the acceleration as
well
and the direction is pointed right at
the center of the galaxy so this is
exactly what you'd expect for that kind
of centripetal acceleration effect so
they've used all these stars and this
guy data to calculate something they
could have calculated pretty easily
another way you know at some level it's
a trivial calculation because we sort of
already knew what the answer is it's
sort of reassuring it gave the right
answer technically it's absolutely
amazing that they can measure an
acceleration directly measure you know
pre the previous you know we think the
acceleration has to be this was all
indirectly inferred right they've
measured it they've measured this
acceleration this tiny acceleration
you want it to point and keep it there
and it's actually surprisingly simple
physics and it's all down to the
conservation of angular momentum
now you might see in in some science
fiction shows like battlestar galactica
or something like that
that they maneuver spacecraft with
thrusters